hey
i gave you 10 years to live your life
[Applause]
now you see me rise and where did that
get you
walked in my shadow
i trained you
see the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you
son it's time for you to take your place
by my side
[Music]
who you really are
who are you
[Applause]
okay hold on everybody
we make a good team
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
this morning
we got the official teaser trailer for
shang qi
and the legend of the ten rings and as
you just saw it did not disappoint it's
actually quite different than i thought
it was going to be like but in a very
very good way
in this trailer we are semi introduced
to several
new characters we finally have the real
mandarin in the mcu
we have aquafina's character katie we
have people like
razer fist and we have an entire plot to
break down so
let's dive into it but of course be sure
to subscribe if you love marvel and
don't want to miss out on anything
that's happening in the mcu and i'm
still doing the captain america shield
giveaway just check out the details in
the description down below
so it looks like we start this trailer
off in china
xiangxi was originally from china this
is where he was raised and we find him
looking at an
old wooden pillar that kind of has a
little hole in it as shanxi touches it
we can see that he's reliving some
memories and judging by his facial
expression they're not exactly good
he touches the pillar then puts his fist
inside of the hole
flash forward to a few scenes later in
the trailer it turns out this hull was
made by him punching it repeatedly over
and over again as a child
and this was part of his training now
this trailer goes through many different
time periods of
shanxi's life and we cut to the present
where he's working as a valet
and a dj and we hear the voice of his
father in the background saying
i gave you 10 years to live your life
and where did that get you
and as he says this we see what shang
chi is up to now
again he's a valet and a dj and he's out
partying with his friends and genuinely
seems to be having a pretty good time
however this seems like one of those
stories where you can't deny who you are
as his father
says time is up i gave you 10 years now
you're coming back
and this is where we start to see a
little bit of his past and how his
father trained him
now side note if you are aware with the
shang chi comics they've actually
changed quite a bit
the reason they are changing some things
like his origin and who his father is
is because the comics back then in the
70s were kind of stereotypical and
racist or at least could be viewed
by some as such so his father in the
movie is in fact
the mandarin the leader of the ten rings
but his father's name is win woo
not fu manchu like the comics and as we
see he's been training chongqi ever
since he was a little kid
we also see death dealer training him as
well one of his father's most trusted
partners
and from here we start to see the
vigorous training that sheng chi was put
through as a kid
a young chiang chi is punching this
wooden pole that we saw repeatedly over
and over
and he stops but deathmaker is there to
make sure that he keeps going
fighting through the pain in which we
see that he eventually gets used to
because when he's a little bit
older he's able to hit it repeatedly
without stopping his father then says
you walked in my shadow and in this
scene we actually see
the ten rings on his arms now the ten
rings is one
a weapon and two an organization that
shang chi's father wen wu
runs and yes in this movie win woo is
the mandarin the leader of the tin rings
organization and he's been training sima
liu's character shanxi
to be a part of this organization to be
a trained killer that nobody can defeat
but at the same time the tin rings are a
physical
thing they're actually weapons in the
comics they're literally rings that you
wear on your fingers but as we see here
in several different scenes the 10 rings
are
indeed rings but they're quite large and
we can see them kept on the mandarin's
arms instead of on his fingers now in
the comics
each ring grants a different ability
some of them being ice blasts fire blast
electronic blasts
the ability to absorb all light around
you and create
complete darkness along with a lot of
other energy abilities
and we actually see the rings being used
a couple of times during the trailer
when his father says he walked in a
shadow we immediately see the rings
being used after
we see somebody punching a table and we
actually see a
blue glow on the arms so we see that the
rings
are being used and judging by the suit
that this person is wearing it looks an
awful lot like the suit that we just saw
the mandarin wearing
and he was wearing the ring so we can
assume that this is him and not
shang chi in this shot here we then hear
his father say i trained you so the most
dangerous people in the world couldn't
kill you and here we see some of the
vigorous training that he was put
through as a boy
and in this little montage of shang chi
training we actually find something very
interesting in the shot of shanghi where
he seems to be in
some type of an arena meant for fighting
we can actually see in the background
behind the change a
captain america shield at least that is
very
very much what it looks like now we're
not actually sure
when in the mcu shanxi takes place it
could take place before the blip
could be after this could actually be
some type of propaganda for
john walker's new captain america it
could also just be graffiti on the wall
perhaps somebody painted the shield
there
it's also been pointed out that this
kind of looks like the tanisha flag
so it could also very well be that
depending on where shang chi
ends up throughout the movie maybe we'll
find out in the movie or maybe it's just
a tiny little easter egg
now the premise of the story is chong
chi was trained as a kid his father
let him go away for 10 years to kind of
live his own life and now his father
wants him to come back and take his
place beside him running the tin rings
organization
now in the comics chongqi does a lot for
his father until it's revealed that his
father isn't exactly
doing good things and that is most
likely the story here if you recall
all the way back to the very first mcu
movie
iron man the tin rings organization was
name dropped as they were the people who
captured tony stark they came back again
in iron man 3 where we were introduced
to a
fake mandarin but now we have the real
mandarin and the real tin rings
organization so i'm curious to see as
how they're going to connect them to the
iron man movies
hopefully there will be some callbacks
now of course xiangxi does not want to
return
to live the life that his father wants
him to live he doesn't want to join his
organization or lead it and he probably
actually
ran away from the organization his
father says i gave you 10 years to live
your life but what he's really probably
saying is
you ran away and i gave you 10 years of
not chasing you so you could kind of get
some stuff out of your system but hey
time's up stop playing around come back
home but shang chi is like
nah however his father tells him that he
can't outrun who he really is
and from here we get some pretty epic
fight scenes with some pretty cool
characters
and the fighting actually looks very
well done it looks like it's a good
combination of actual hand-to-hand
combat fighting with a little bit of cgi
animation thrown in there
here we see some characters working for
the mandarin trying to take out shang
chi
we see razer fist who was a big shang
chi enemy in the comics but in the
comics it's actually
both of his hands that are replaced with
razor swords whereas here we only see
one of them replaced we're also
introduced to zai ling
who is actually xiang chi sister and the
daughter of wenwoo
aka the mandarin and it's been said in
the movie that she's actually going to
help
shanghi take down the 10 rings now there
is a mysterious character that we do see
in this trailer and he is wearing and
using the tin rings now i believe this
is the character that dallas liu is
going to be playing
dallas leo right now is playing an
undisclosed character
in the movie but in this shot right here
of dallas leo fighting chang-chi where
he's wearing the rings we can kind of
see his face
and it does look like him however the
character that he is playing
is unknown right now we also have
michelle yeoh who is playing an unknown
character as well and we don't really
see her in this trailer
however in the trailer shangshi does
fight a woman wearing green who is
wearing a face mask
so we don't really get a good look at
her but this could be the character
fa lo su aka the cursed lotus
this outfit looks like it could be an
adaptation of the comic book outfit of
the curse lotus and the curse lotus in
the comics is actually the half-sister
to shang chi
and the leader of the criminal
organization oriental expeditors
she is constantly at battle with her
brother in the comics and she actually
has access to the elixir of life
so she's practically immortal and she
can hypnotize people with her words and
i wouldn't be surprised if this is who
michelle yo is playing
now in the final scenes we hear the
mandarin chongqi's father say you can't
outrun
who you really are and then after shang
chi beats up a bunch of people on a bus
we see akufina's character katie ask
who are you and this obviously isn't
because she doesn't know who he is
they're best friends in the movie but
she didn't know about his
past she doesn't know that he's the
master of kung fu
and it's been said that she's not going
to have an insanely heavy role in this
movie but
a good role nonetheless and that's it
for the breakdown of the teaser trailer
of xiang chi be sure to subscribe and
hit the notification bell so you don't
miss out on any future shanghai related
videos plus other marvel and other
superhero movies as well
be sure to let me know what you think
about this trailer in the comments down
below how excited are you for shanghi
and the legend of the ten rings don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof